it's
pretty Sprite pretty is that how you say
it pretty spell
white Byron Messias he's here bu go
people keep [__] your name up they
keep calling you Byron Messias it
doesn't matter but I'm saying is this a
thing that happens yeah that's a like I
I mean you know is it frustrating for
you coming to the states and like DJs
are just you know no tomato tomato
doesn't matter tomato tomato once they
know you know once they know they know
and they won't mess up again well hey
dude congratulations on all the success
obviously talibans is a gigantic massive
smash record thanks for that um you're
from the Caribbean um which I think is
like obviously like you're from is it St
kit yeah yeah what what is it like cuz I
I've I've only been to the Dr in terms
of of like islands in the world I've
only been to one Island in my life and
it's the Dominican Republic I heard I'm
slacking I heard I got to get to like
the real Carib we all know why you was
down
there what is your hypoth why do you
think I was there why do you think I
what is your assumption on why it's it's
a beautiful place but why do you think I
there I mean who doesn't want to be down
there but why do you think I was there
the way you said I don't know vacation
maybe D
podcast I went there for my honeymoon
bro
okay he doesn't believe me
honeymoon it was a full moon the Dr of
course who that's a single man though
huh when you when you went were you
single like in out of a Rel I've always
been single good good for you so when
you went did you uh did you enjoy the
local talents at all I went from music
bro I don't know what you're talking
about you just looked away and then
picked up a Sprite Which is a real
talltail if you're full of [__] he's
like I don't know what you're talking
about hey this is good sprite though
when you went to the Dr did you try
mamana what it's the drink they have
it's got like a wood inside of it it's
like why it's like the drink they have
at all the resorts it's like a Dominican
thing oh no no no and then they have
their own beer El Presidente did you try
their beer no you're not a big
drinker no not really well if you were
to drink what's your preferred
alcohol um Hennessy Henny [__] I like
that that's like that 2009 energy you
know what I'm saying nobody's drinking
Hennessy anymore everyone switched over
during the pandemic they're all off of
tequila and 1942 and Don Julio such
right yeah yeah people are I appreciate
you sticking with Team Hennessy we need
more Hennessy guys in the game right
now um but yo tell me what what was it
like growing up in the Caribbean
man I mean it wasn't easy but it still
wasn't rough for me you know yeah yeah
always had support from Friends peers
and yeah you know family so yeah what
inspired you to uh I guess pick up the
mic start writing start rapping same
friends your friends yeah what about
like in terms of like were there any
artists that you gravitated towards yeah
plenty who were like your like you know
cuz for me like as a kid it was like we
had like Snoop Bone Thugs 50 Eminem
Outcast you know Kanye like who were
your guys when you were growing up
listen to a lot of
Mexico popcor popcor you
know like Caribbean wise and there was
so many um local talents as well to know
like from where you were at yeah yeah it
school so yeah that was basically how my
whole soul was at the time yo